[Musique]
où que ce soit qu'on habite le paysage
il est là il est immédiatement là en
suisse les paysages font partie des
fondements du pays
c'est une carte postale qui est là grâce
aux paysans on va jusqu'à payer pour
entretenir la beauté des lieux
c'est quand même beaucoup plus attrayant
paysage comme ça dans tout le pays si
tout le monde joue le jeu
pourquoi pas
[Musique]
c'est un chemin et qui est très très
identitaire de la grande qualité de
cette campagne l émail et de tout un tas
d'éléments qui font grande qualité dont
ces chemins de chaîne
natacha guillaumont qui enseigne à de
futurs aménagistes veut nous montrer à
quel point en suisse chaque détail dans
le paysage et réfléchie et entretenu ses
chaînes en sont un parfait exemple
ils se retrouvent le long de nombreuses
routes en dehors de genève et ils sont
protégés ces îles ont été plantés il ya
cent à deux cents ans c'est exceptionnel
d'avoir des routes planté vous voyez par
exemple quand il meurt en garde les
arbres abattus parce que c'est des abris
pour tous les insectes et la micro vie
et microphone dont on a besoin et
compris la petite faune des rongeurs
donc ça c'est des corridors biologiques
ce1 d'abord qui doivent circuler avant
nous ces chaînes font partie du paysage
et on veut que ça reste comme ça
ça ne date pas d'hier que ce petit pays
où 70% du territoire et montagneux
s'intéresse à la valeur de ses paysages
au début du 20e siècle le débat sur la
protection des paysages et déjà entamé
en suisse mais il faudra attendre 1962
pour qu'on en chasse la notion de
paysage dans la constitution du pays
une première en europe on a déjà compris
à ce moment là que derrière un paysage
il y a les agriculteurs ici ce serait de
la forêt ci avait pas d'agriculture on
n'aurait rien du tout n'aurait que des
forêts mais quand on regarde dans le
paysage ici toutes ses terrasses c'est
l'agriculteur qui l'a fait c'est lui qui
structure le paysage aujourd'hui
regarde moi ça comme c'est beau
c'est plaisant d'habiter dans un si beau
pays des gens qui viennent à moi marius
panassié est un éleveur du val d'hérens
dans le canton du valais il nous conduit
vers la halle taz une zone de pâturage
ou en montagne
ça fait plaisir tout soit faussée
entretenu sinon on aurait de la forêt
jusqu'aux portes du village
[Musique]
cet éleveur possède un troupeau de
vaches d'hérens typique de sa région
c'est les vaches laitières elle donne du
lait ont fait du fromage à raclette ici
au lait cru
un excellent fromage et puis c'est aussi
des fois ma foi on doit les tuer quand
même hein sinon on en a trop une
excellente races à viande sa alu réveil
mais ici la vache d'hérens a aussi un
autre mandat bien particulier celui
d'entretenir le paysage c'est des
tondeuses à gazon professionnelles elles
vont partout c'est presque des chamois
et du coup tous ses alpages et toute
cette nature est entretenu et on a une
biodiversité magique et sebo mélèzes et
ses chalets qui ont des centaines
d'années que nos ancêtres ont fait c'est
notre devoir
les entretenir et de continuer à
perdurer ce qu'ils ont fait parce qu'ils
ont fait un boulot phénoménal
[Musique]
tout en bas dans la vallée du rhône
dominic brisby possède un vignoble
unique à flanc de montagne
cela fait partie du paysage ici depuis
très longtemps d'être les romains ont
passé dans la région la vigne est arrivé
a été cultivé par les gens de l'endroit
ces vignes s'élève en terrasse avec
comme principale caractéristique ces
grands murs de pierre on les voit
partout on reconnaît les murs comme les
châteaux
c'est les mêmes pierres c'est beaucoup
de travail pour ceux qui ont construit
mais avec beaucoup de temps aussi
on voit que c'est du travail fait à la
main avec beaucoup de temps et beaucoup
d'amour aussi pour le pour les faire ils
sont droit des vieux murs de qui sont là
depuis fort longtemps et qui tiennent
toujours
[Musique]
entretenir ses murs de pierres ou bien
faire du pâturage dans la haute montagne
est tout de même compliqué et coûteux
surtout quand c'est pour le bonheur de
nos yeux
mais les gouvernements en suisse et y
ont pensé il subventionne des
agriculteurs pour entretenir le paysage
chaque élément paysager a une valeur
différente selon le projet dans lequel
il se trouve
mature amy est l'un des gestionnaires de
ce programme
il nous donne en exemple ces arbres
fruitiers
ici on se trouve dans une région de
plaine donc les beaucoup plus facile
pour l'agriculteur de supprimer son
arbre est d'arriver avec une grande
machine pour exploiter de manière assez
intensive toute la surface
l'agriculteur va recevoir de l'argent
pour l'entretien de cet arbre qui va le
voir le taille et d'une certaine façon
il va devoir laisser de l'herbe ce qu'on
appelle une bordure tampon autour de
l'arbre il n'y aura pas de fauche
on aura une prairie un peu plus naturel
autour de l'arbre et en fonction de ça
les subsides sont calculées et plus le
travail fourni par l'agriculteur sera
important plus le subside plus là
l'aspect financier sera important aussi
[Musique]
chaque année donc la confédération
suisse des blocs près de 400 millions de
dollars pour financer divers projets
liés à la beauté des paysages au
maintien de l'alpage et à la
biodiversité
cet argent nous apporte une plus-value
pour pouvoir faire entretenir un mur
entretenir un paysage dessous tout à
fait sain pas cohérent
[Musique]
alors évidemment s'il ya plus de
paiements directs les des morceaux
entiers seraient abandonnées bacquet et
les murs qu'ils y seraient bain à la
limite il est il tomberait il tomberait
puis voilà il y aura personne qui les
remettra à 11 puis ce serait du sauvage
on va dire ça comme ça
deux thèmes si ça d un petit amat on est
à peu près je crois à 50% de notre venue
vient de cette rétribution
alors maintenant de la mondialisation
les vaches qui broutent maintenant c'est
pas concurrentiel du tout et si on n'a
pas une aide du gouvernement mais s'en
sort montagne c'est pas possible de
maintenir une agriculture viable
en vertu des accords internationaux
la suisse ne peut subventionner
directement son agriculture mais le pays
veut développer son autosuffisance
ainsi grâce à cette aide paysagère et de
biodiversité
l'état peut soutenir ses agriculteurs on
n'a pas des immenses exploitations comme
aux états unis ou au canada
l'exploitation moyenne en suisse elle
est de trente hectares et si on va les
allées de 10 hectares donc on a assez
structure qui nous permettent de
produire à bas prix et avec ses
paiements directs effectivement on leur
permet de continuer à entretenir des
terrains qui sont en pente d'avoir
toujours quand même une production
agricole
c'est quand même important d'avoir des
paysans qui même dans le mode actuel de
production mondiale ne sont pas
rentables mais ils produisent qu'on
mange on est là pour faire ce que vous
mangez ciapa de paysans mange plus un
pour maintenir la beauté de ses paysages
et assurer la pérennité de la
biodiversité
la suisse a choisi d'en financer
l'entretien mais avec tous les enjeux de
société
on peut se demander si c'est un luxe ou
un bien essentiel elle c'est vrai que si
on compare à une agriculture dans un
pays en voie de développement
c'est une politique d'un magret colle un
peu de luxe c'est vrai on peut se le
permettre mais si on n'avait pas ça on
n'aurait plus d'agriculture en suisse
donc c'est aussi un choix qu'on a fait
[Musique]
les politiques suisses ont inspiré le
reste de l'europe depuis plus de 20 ans
la convention européenne du paysage
un site à protéger et à prendre en
compte les paysages dans tous les
projets de développement tout ce qui est
modernité un champ éolien une une usine
de méthanisation du photovoltaïque ou
une maison qui une maison récente qui se
construit dans un paysage où vous n'avez
que des anciennes fermes peut poser un
objet de controverse
donc paysage a une valeur quelque part
de reconstruction du lien social du bien
commun c'est une manière de leur faire
un peu de démocratie dans quel type de
paysage je veux vivre
le paysage il est tout le temps en
mouvement ça veut dire que comme il est
tout le temps en mouvement faut tout le
temps s'en occuper et tout le temps s'en
occuper ça veut dire rappeler aux élus
qu on peut pas construire partout
rappeler aux forestiers qu'on peut pas
couper les arbres n'importe comment
s'occuper du paysage est un travail de
tous les jours de tous les instants
comme respirer
c'est la même chose au québec
gerald de dôme on aimerait bien que
toutes ces idées ces politiques et ces
débats sur le paysage prennent leur
envol ici c'est sûr que donc des besoins
primaires qui sont peut-être passées
avant le paysage mais je pense quand
même que tout le monde à la fois que la
santé physique et mentale devraient
avoir accès à des paysages des clubs de
vie de qualité
et dans le contexte actuel c'est pas
normal non plus qu effectivement il ya
que des gens qui ont les moyens qu'ils
ont accès aux paysages
[Musique]